gestresster Ramadan Vlog Nummer 7
gestern war es halt echt schön da war
ich noch nichts anderes diesen fetten
Blumenstrauß bekommen heute habe ich
dann Videos gedreht ganz viele geniale
und richtig leckere Rezepte aber mein
Zeitmanagement war eine Katastrophe ich
habe dann ganz schnell Suppe und
Fingerfood gemacht das war nämlich für
Hamza und ich war heute eingeladen bei
meiner Freundin und dann habe ich den
Abend einfach nur ausklingen lassen ich
kann zwar echt auf den letzten Drücker
aber wisst ihr was ich schön finde meine
Freundin ist keine Muslima und hat uns
trotzdem alle drei passenden Mädels
ziemlich stark eingeladen und das fand
ich echt schön sag mal dann verbindet
einfach